bonjour merci beaucoup d'être notre
invité politique ce matin lisez
l'agriculture et de la souveraineté
alimentaire vous êtes également premier
vice-président du MoDem on va parler
évidemment de sujets pratiques avec vous
en étant 100 pendant 20 minutes pour une
interview en partenariat avec la presse
régionale représentée par Julien Lecuyer
de la Voix du Nord qu'on est ravi de
retrouver aujourd'hui
il y a beaucoup de sujets mais d'abord
question politique sur la loi
immigration il y a une tribune qui a été
signée de parlementaire de la majorité
présidentielle et de la nuque qui a été
publiée cette semaine qui plaide en
faveur de la régularisation des
travailleurs sans papiers notamment dans
les métiers en tension est-ce que vous
soutenez les députés modem qui ont signé
cette tribune université d'opinion c'est
sur ces sujets de l'immigration il faut
qu'on arrive à tenir à la fois un
objectif sinon il y aura pas de
d'intégration réussie qui soit celui
d'une immigration qui soit plus choisie
si je peux dire et moins subi mais on
sait à quel point les phénomènes
migratoires sont très forts on voit bien
ce qui est en train de se passer en
Italie de nouveau
parce que quand la fin vous pousse quand
la guerre vous pousse on peut raconter
ce qu'on veut ici sur un bureau les gens
partent de chez eux pour essayer de
trouver un territoire qui leur soit plus
favorable et ça peut s'entendre et se
comprend donc on a besoin de trouver un
équilibre entre la gestion de ses flux
migratoires et derrière flux migratoire
il y a des gens il y a des réalités
humaines donc faut c'est des mots qui
sont un peu abruptes donc ils ont eu
raison de la signer avec des pins
premier élément donc essayer de gérer
les flux et en même temps le faire dans
des conditions raisonnables et qu'il
soit acceptable parce qu'on peut pas
accepter que tous ceux qui veulent venir
chez nous puissent venir chez nous parce
que sinon on crée des déséquilibres ils
sont trop forts c'est tout le sujet de
ces questions migratoires et sans être
rotage d'un camp ou d'un autre sur ces
questions là et le point d'équilibre il
est très compliqué à trouver on va se
dire les choses comme elles sont nous le
fait que moi je trouve pas inintéressant
qu'on puisse se poser la question à un
moment d'aller devant les Français parce
que chacun a du mal à sortir de sa
posture dans cette affaire elle est
devant les Français c'est-à-dire
qu'est-ce que vous voulez un moment on
ouvre la porte la question référendum
référendaire donc il faut d'abord non
mais c'est bien la question qui a été
posée
on se disait ce que là il y a pas moyen
que de faire des Français juge de paix
de question qui sont très en otage de
ceux qui d'un côté ou de l'autre essaie
de radicaler les radicaliser les
positions en tout cas je m'interroge
vous vous y serez favorable moi je je
répète je m'interroge je me dis
qu'est-ce qui peut faire qu'on est un
débat qui soit un débat éclairé et
apaisé par un débat d'une caricature
contre une autre vous voyez ce que je
veux dire une tribune comme ça est-ce
que ça risque pas de fracturer la
majorité en tout cas de l'abîme
notamment le remarquandil le patron
d'horizon moi j'ai vu
on sait bien que sur la majorité depuis
2017-2018 cette question migratoire est
une question qui parfois a fait des
divergences à l'intérieur des groupes
enfin je pense pas
c'est pas une surprise c'est pas une
surprise mais ça fait 6 ans que je
connais cette majorité elle a été moins
à se fracturé que bien des majorités
avant elle enfin on va dire des choses
comme ils sont elle a toujours été la
solidarité alors qu'il puisse y avoir
des expressions est une chose la
l'expression ne doit pas éviter qu'à un
moment on essaie de trouver un point de
consensus mais le point de consensus il
est pas seulement dans la majorité c'est
qu'est-ce que disent les LR qu'est-ce
que disent les gens qui à gauche sont
plus modérés qui essaient de en fait de
résoudre ce problème en conscience c'est
pas avec des postures en même temps
c'est difficile alors il vaut mieux il
vaut mieux trouver un accord avec les LR
en accord avec la gauche ça peut pas
être zéro régularisation d'un côté ou
toute régularisation pardon c'est pas en
même temps c'est un point d'équilibre là
en même temps est un point d'équilibre
dans cette affaire on a besoin de
trouver l'équilibre vous ne trouverez
pas sur un chemin qui soit un chemin du
Yaka faucon et ceux qui nous ont
expliqué dans d'autres pays du monde de
l'autre côté de l'Atlantique par exemple
que ils allaient mettre des clôtures des
barrières des murs et qu'ils allaient
empêcher les immigrés de venir ils ont
jamais réussi à le faire donc c'est pas
la peine de d'avoir des postures dont on
sait qu'on ne les tient pas par ailleurs
on a besoin de travailler c'est des
questions du dérèglement climatique des
dérèglements géopolitiques pour que dans
un certain nombre de pays les choses ne
se déstabilisent pas parce que c'est ça
ce qui produit les flux migrants avec ce
texte François Bayrou il dit c'est un
texte utile mais pas essentiel est-ce
qu'il faut y renoncer si un accord n'est
pas trouvé on verra mais en tout cas il
y a des choses moi je quand j'étais aux
Relations avec le Parlement j'avais en
charge les budgets en particulier de
ceux qui gérait
les dossiers des gens qui font des
demandes d'asile on a un sujet et ça
c'est du réglementaire et ça c'est de la
politique publique c'est vieux comme on
a plutôt amélioré les choses mais on a
besoin d'accélérer procédures parce que
quand vous avez des gens à qui vous
répondez deux trois quatre ou cinq ans
plus tard compte tenu des recours et de
évidemment vous êtes dans une situation
où c'est compliqué de les raccompagner
aux frontières et en même temps vous
n'avez en scène parfois votre
impuissance donc on a besoin d'avoir des
procédures et c'est vrai que ça mais ça
ça peut passer par règlement c'est ce
que je viens de nous dire ce n'est pas
obligé par un projet
Bayrou a raison c'est-à-dire que
essayons de segmenter les problèmes
d'abord les obligations Qt le territoire
est-ce qu'on peut pas les régler on doit
pouvoir les régler autrement par la loi
parce que ce n'est pas la loi la loi
elle est posée là-dessus faut juste
qu'on ait des politiques publiques qui
le fasse mieux donc c'est plutôt comme
ça qu'il faut qu'on essaie de cheminer
c'est vrai c'est plutôt la question
c'est de savoir est-ce qu'il vaut mieux
pas finalement arrêter les frais sur ce
texte voir la voie réglementaire
s'éviter un nouveau 49-3 au risque d'une
motion de censure
ou bien essayer malgré tout de passer en
force l'action c'est pas de patient fort
sur un sujet comme ça c'est pas mon avis
le sujet oui bien qu'on a ça a été
évoqué quand même je veux dire au sommet
de l'État rendez mon avis
je vous donne le mien je pense qu'on est
dans un moment où les où les citoyens je
pense qu'en une partie des groupes
politiques et des partis politiques ont
un peu besoin d'apaisement et si on
vient du sujet je pense qu'on est
essayons d'avancer sur ce sur quoi on
peut avancer d'un point de vue pratique
la majorité aussi a besoin d'apaisement
mais tout le monde a besoin d'apaisement
je trouve pas qu'un pays puisse
durablement fonctionner quand en
permanence il y a de la tension on voit
ce que ça peut produire dans un certain
nombre de pays on voit bien comment la
tension aux États-Unis elle a produit à
la fin ce qu'elle a produit au Capitole
donc on a besoin quand même de se dire
que il y a des débats qui sont complexes
il y a des débats qu'on peut trancher
d'abord par de la réglementation de la
politique publique peut-être qu'il y
aura besoin d'un texte peut-être qu'il y
aura besoin
qui peuvent aller parce que le compromis
et le dialogue c'est pas venait sur ma
position sinon je vote les
gens de républicain ça peut être les
républicains mais même à gauche mais
même à gauche il y a un certain nombre
de gens qui savent très bien qu'on peut
pas régulariser tous les sans-papiers il
y a un certain nombre de gens qui savent
très bien qu'on peut pas faire autre
chose d'ailleurs quand ils étaient au
gouvernement il passait leur temps y
compris il y a pas si longtemps sous
Monsieur Hollande à nous expliquer qu'on
pouvait pas accueillir les réfugiés
syriens et d'ailleurs ça nous avait été
reprochés par les Allemands donc faut
pas tous ces gens qui viennent vous
donner des leçons aujourd'hui ils sont
chacun dans leur posture comme si un
moment il sera ils seront pas appelés
parce que je leur souhaite à être en
responsabilité et donc faut toujours
penser que ce que vous dites un jour ça
peut être vous devez vous devenez
comptable quand vous êtes en
responsabilité une question sur Jean-Luc
Mélenchon oui on parlait de de la gauche
on va parler d'une certaine gauche la
France insoumise à l'occasion du 50e
anniversaire du coup d'État contre
Salvador Allende au Chili et Jean-Luc
Mélenchon adressé un parallèle entre
Emmanuel Macron et Elisabeth borne et
Augusto Pinochet je le cite ils ont le
même visage bestial commencé à Santiago
du Chili qu'est-ce que ça vous inspire
cette phrase
plus rien ne m'inspire chez Jean-Luc
Mélenchon d'autre chose que l'excès d'un
homme qui d'abord n'a pas accepté ses
défaites successives or il devrait faire
un travail sur lui-même parce que c'est
comme ça c'est la vie je crois que
c'était aussi les défaites de quelqu'un
qui cherche à toute force et par une
surenchère des verbales mais il prend de
très lourdes responsabilités à faire ça
pourquoi il est exactement comme quand
il fait ça comme quand monsieur Trump
dit on nous a volé l'élection vous voyez
ce que je veux dire et à ce moment là
vous voyez ce que ça peut produire dans
des et après il est le même à dire il
faut attention la violence donc c'est un
bout de feu moi j'avais dit à l'époque
en 2018 quand il était au moment des au
moment des des la crise des gilets
jaunes que c'est les pouces au crime sur
insurrectionnel et moi je trouve que
dans le moment qu'on traverse si on est
un responsable politique si on est un
irresponsable politique c'est autre
chose mais quand on est un responsable
politique on ne doit pas avoir des mots
comme ça qui sont objectivement Pinochet
c'est des millions de morts Pinochet
c'est des gens qui étaient emprisonnés
monsieur Monsieur Mélenchon aurait été
sous le régime de pélo Pinochet il
aurait été en prison et regrettable ça
nous aurait privé de sa parole vous
voyez ce que je veux dire comparer une
grande démocratie comme la nôtre et la
démocratie c'est accepter quand vous
êtes au pouvoir de supporter rejette et
les filles et RN en dehors de l'arc
républicain est-ce qu'il y a pas une
forme d'aussi de caricature qui risque
aussi d'être de vous rapprocher ça n'a
rien à voir avec la pression que vous
posez pardon sur est-ce que nous
ressemblerions de près de loin ou de
plus près ou de plus loin et puis nos
chefs je veux dire c'est grotesque
franchement de dire des choses pareilles
c'est quoi qui peut croire une chose
pareille dans ce pays donc et par
ailleurs moi il vous aura pas échappé
que le Président de la République en il
a reçu les partis politiques à
Saint-Denis
il a reçu l'ensemble de l'arc de ceux
qui sont c'était pas gagné au départ
j'en sais rien mais en tout cas ils
étaient là alors après les mêmes qui
vous disent vous les écartez trop loin
quand vous les mettez avec vous c'est
vous les banalisez bon il va falloir que
chacun choisisse son camp camarade comme
disait l'autre parce que soit ils sont
dans l'arc républicain au sens que ils
sont dans le dans une démocratie ils ont
été élu donc on n'a pas à remettre en
cause les choix des éleveurs le
président voilà c'est ça l'arc ou alors
on les exclut mais ça peut pas être on
peut pas se faire reprocher des exclure
et les inclure parce que là on a quelque
chose un discours qui va pas et moi j'ai
entendu chez vos confrères de dire vous
avez vous avez normalisé qui Bardella
qui vont pas alors si on les invite pas
on nous aurait dit vous les avez exclus
moi je pense que la démocratie nous
donne ce qu'elle nous donne les citoyens
ils choisissent c'est des parties qui
sont légaux qui ne sont pas interdits
il faut faire avec il faut surtout
combattre leurs idées faut surtout faire
en sorte que ces gens-là ne prospèrent
pas parce qu'ils prospèrent sur le
malheur des gens et le populisme c'est
ça qu'il faut faire le reste c'est de la
littérature en fait c'est des postures
c'est des jeux de posture et donc
Monsieur Mélenchon comme les autres mais
j'ai Mélenchon il se nourrissent ça s'il
y a pas tout ça il n'existe pas Monsieur
Mélenchon parce que et pourtant il reste
très populaire vous avez vu les sondages
Harris qui ont été diffusés qu'il était
un populaire je vous dis si la passa il
est il est pas simplement il y a pas de
majorité
autour de lui
aujourd'hui il a fait 16-18 20% c'est
très remarquable
mais
j'en sais rien mais en tout cas
toutes les élections successives il a
pas dépassé cette barre là donc 20%
alors sauf dans les régimes qui soutient
parfois peut-être au Venezuela ou
ailleurs avec 20 % faites pas une
majorité c'est comme il y a un sujet
parmi les sujets inquiétudes des
Français il y a la question de la vie
chère notamment dans l'alimentaire Bruno
Le Maire souhaite des négociations
commerciales plusieurs fois par an entre
producteurs et distributeurs et non plus
seulement des négociations annuelles
est-ce que les agriculteurs risquent
d'être les grands perdants c'est
certainement pas l'objectif et j'ai noté
avec attention ce qui a dit Bruno Le
Maire je croyais
certains de vos confrères qui est pas
être question que nous revenions sur ce
qui a été les grands principes posés par
le Président de la République
depuis 2017 qui est celui de la
rémunération agricole pour une raison
simple si on rémunère pas les
agriculteurs on pourra toujours là aussi
sur les plateaux dire que on perd en
souvreté que on est plus autosuffisant
fruits et légumes en viande etc ça
aurait été simplement le produit d'une
incapacité à rémunérer donc on est dans
un moment inflationniste pendant 15 ans
sur l'alimentation on a été pas stable
on a été déflationniste c'est-à-dire que
vous étiez à 100 et vous étiez à 90 ou
95 10 années plus tard il y a aucun
système économique qui puisse résister à
ça et donc il était temps qu'on sorte de
ses spirales ou au fond c'est
l'agriculture qui faisait l'ajustement
pris après qui ai besoin entre la grande
distribution et les industries
agroalimentaires de discussions qui
soient plus active et qui est plus de
réactivité quand vous avez une inflation
qui fait plus 5 - 5 sur certains ou plus
15 - 15 sur des produits
en tout cas matière première mais enfin
dans une dans un produit que dans un
kilo de pâtes vous avez la part des
céréales elle est assez faible par
rapport à l'emballage à la
transformation au salaire et que je
sache les salaires nous pas abaissé et
c'est tant mieux ils ont même plutôt
augmenté et c'est tant mieux que je
sache l'énergie il suffit d'aller à une
pompe essence pour comprendre que
manifestement ça n'a pas tout à fait
baissé et donc
vous en assurer que les agriculteurs ne
soient pas perdants mais c'est la loi en
fait on va s'en assurer parce que la
matière première agricole elle est
préservée et je n'entends pas que nous
en rabattu en la tuer d'ailleurs Bruno
Le Maire non plus la redit hier le
principe c'est la rémunération de la
matière première agricole à son prix par
ailleurs on demande aux agriculteurs de
faire des efforts sur un certain nombre
de transition bon
une transition comment comment vous
allez les inciter parce que en effet il
y a la transition écologique elle doit
se faire sujet
la première façon de les inciter c'est
si ça vous coûte un peu plus cher à vous
agriculteurs ça sera payé un peu plus
cher parce que si c'est pour l'ordi on
vous demande de faire des efforts de
productivité au fond
de baisse parfois de tel ou telle
difficulté qui se serait posée sur un
terme et que ce n'est pas trouvé dans la
rémunération là aussi on parle dans le
vide premier élément pour assumer les
transitions c'est qu'elles soient
rémunérées et la seule manière de les
rémunérer c'est qu'elle soit dans les
prix deuxième élément il faut qu'on les
accompagne budgétairement ce que j'ai
annoncé ce week-end dans une région que
vous connaissez bien oui
je me doute à terre de gym c'est des
moyens d'accompagnement de la transition
pour vous donner qu'un seul exemple 250
millions sur le budget plus de 150
millions sur France 2030 sur la
transition pour les produits phytos
c'est quoi concrètement c'est de la
recherche
de l'innovation pour trouver des
solutions alternatives
du matériel pour réduire l'utilisation
la dose qu'on met l'hectare sur un
certain nombre de produits ça c'est du
concret et donc ça ça vient améliorer ou
réduire plutôt le coût que c'est l'État
va accompagner les agriculteurs sur la
sur la transition c'est ce que c'est ce
que vous nous dites mais beaucoup de
millions sur la table est-ce que ça
s'accompagne aussi de contraintes plus
forte c'est à dire des des dates plus
resserrées pour se transformer pour
transitionner c'est l'objectif de la
planification je trouve que l'exercice
de planification il est parfois comment
dire il peut être parfois effrayant
quand vous regardez parce qu'en fait il
y a d'un côté faut réduire l'idée c'est
la trajectoire de réduction des produits
phytos de l'autre côté faut être sobre à
l'hectare mais on sait que la contrainte
climatique et le besoin en eau va être
plus grand donc faut être sobre à
l'hectare il y a plus d'hectares sans
doute qui sont irrigués d'un autre côté
il faut préserver la biodiversité dans
trois quatrième côté faut produire pour
se nourrir et d'un cinquième côté il va
falloir produire plus de biomasse pour
couvrir les besoins de carburant de
bureau source et d'un certain nombre de
choses et stocker du carbone bon la
planification elle vient poser tout à la
fois ce qui est quand même mieux que ce
qu'on a fait pendant des dizaines
d'années c'est à dire osé par si l'eau
refuser les phytos
entre chaque et moi je trouve que
l'exercice qui est porté par la première
ministre et l'ensemble des équipes qui
sont autour d'elle et les ministres que
nous sommes c'est un exercice de
lucidité de crédibilité il y a l'affaire
de la réduction des pesticides c'est
Grenelle de l'environnement Grenelle de
l'environnement vous souvenez c'était à
15 ans et depuis 15 ans on n'a pas
vraiment bien progressé on a produit des
interdictions parfois très national on a
pris des alternatives on en a reculé
certaines pourquoi parce qu'on s'est
retrouvé face à des impasses oui mais
est-ce que les intéressés on fait
seulement c'est c'est les instituts
techniques l'inrale et les agriculteurs
dans leur chambre pardon s'il faut faire
de la recherche génétique ou de la
recherche sur les semences c'est tout le
monde qui doit le faire et avec la
puissance publique je dis souvent que
l'interdiction produit pas la solution
on l'a sous les yeux on interdit les
néonicotinoïdes on n'a pas la solution
moi j'ai entendu des gens comme Monsieur
Jadot savamment nous expliquer à des
tribunes qui avaient une solution la
vérité c'est qu'on l'a pas donc mais ça
ne veut pas dire qu'il faut rabattre
pour autant vous voyez ce que je veux
dire il y a pas un double c'est il faut
chercher les solutions et donc le
travail qu'on fait de planification sur
sujet c'est quelles sont les molécules
dont on peut penser qu'elles sont à
risque ou qu'elles sont trop utilisées
quelle est la trajectoire qu'on peut se
donner quelles sont les alternatives
qu'on essaie de chercher on a fait
quelque chose c'est ça un exemple
concret le glyphosate on a baissé 30% la
consommation de glyphosate on n'a pas
produit une interdiction on a dit quels
sont les usages sur lesquels on peut
évoluer et les réduire il y a des cas
l'agriculture de conservation des sols
qui est bonne pour le carbone où il y a
besoin d'un peu de glyphosate il y a des
cas on peut s'en passer là où on peut
s'en passer on s'en passe donc c'est
comme ça qu'on va crédibiliser les
choses c'est à dire la planif ça donne
des trajectoires et des moyens et il
faut essayer de pas perturber les
trajectoires même si la vie fait que les
trajectoires sont parfois perturbées
c'est comme ça qu'on va y arriver
à terme l'objectif c'est quand même
qu'on utilise moins d'énergie non
renouvelable et d'énergie et maîtrise de
gaz à effet de serre il n'y a pas
d'alternative aujourd'hui sur le
tracteur parce que celui qui montre un
tracteur électrique de 480 chevaux il va
vite s'enfoncer dans le sol voyez c'est
un peu lourd bon donc l'objectif c'est
de dire on fait de la défiscalisation
qu'on viendra remettre sur d'autres
formes de transition pour l'agriculture
mais qui vient pas pénaliser la
compétitivité mais on ne supprime pas le
agriculteurs ne font pas perdants aucun
agriculture c'est qu'il soit pas perdre
après faut trouver la tuyauterie mais
faut trouver la tuyauterie mais on peut
pas dire
concerne agriculture
l'objectif c'est qu'aucun agriculteur ne
soit perdant voilà donc on va trouver
les dispositions qui fiscales qui
d'accompagnement qui de défiscalisation
d'une autre nature qui permettent
d'accompagner
c'est simple c'est si c'est 70 il y a au
moins 70 qui retourne à l'agriculture
donc c'est pas quelque chose qui vient
taper je sais qu'il y a eu des
inquiétudes ça ne vient pas taper la
compétitivité ça vient accompagner on
peut pas dire il faut passer d'une
fiscalité brune vers une fesse qui est
fiscalité verte
là c'est un milliard 3 et dire on touche
rien à cette niche fiscale mais comme on
est parfois en particulier sur ce sujet
sur des impasses retrouver d'autres
voisins pour donner de la compétitivité
à nous agriculteurs vous avez juste une
question sur les propos de d'Ursula
vanderlian la présidente de la
Commission européenne vous l'avez
probablement entendu elle a parlé du
fait de conclure les accords Mercosur de
donc qui pourrait lier l'Union
européenne avec des pays notamment
d'Amérique du Sud d'ici la fin de
l'année c'est un accord qui ne plaît
plus tellement à l'état français n'a
jamais plus vraiment à date et dans les
conditions qui sont qui sont celles
posées est-ce que vous vous dites à
l'Union européenne non ce n'est pas
possible à l'heure actuelle de
construire de ces dossiers mais je vais
vous répondre quand même enfin le
ministre de l'Agriculture que vous êtes
quand vous savez je réponds à peu près
toujours aux questions qu'on me pose
j'ai pas la réputation de faire autre
chose
la question qui est posée par la France
c'est dire on a signé des accords de
Paris on essaie de les faire de les
faire appliquer y compris c'était la
stratégie du greenleal à l'espace
européen si on signe des accords avec
des gens qui ne le respectent pas sur la
déforestation sur la lutte contre les
gaz à effet de serre alors c'est pas la
peine de signer les accords de Paris
c'est pas la peine de demander aux
européens et aux agriculteurs européens
de les respecter dans les accords
internationaux vous voyez ce que je veux
dire donc le Mercosur pourquoi pas dès
lors que dans cet accord c'est ce que
réclame le président de la République et
c'est ce qui fait que ça bloque
aujourd'hui alors après un vendeur layen
dit quelque chose faut pas oublier qu'il
y a quelques élections aussi dans ces
pays-là dans l'intervalle au Brésil mais
ailleurs
mais l'idée de dire que on laisse faire
des accords internationaux qui ne
viennent pas respecter des grands
accords internationaux que sont ceux de
Paris et donc c'est ce qu'on appelle les
causes miroirs ou les clauses de
réciprocité donc la France continue à
dire on a besoin d'un accord et moi-même
comme ils disent de la culture je pense
qu'on a besoin d'échanges y compris dans
le dérèglement climatique y compris
agricoles parce qu'on peut pas dire on
veut bien le vin et les spiritueux en
dehors de nos frontières et pas être en
compétition avec d'autres sur d'autres
sujets mais dans des règles qui ne
nuisent pas la planète et donc c'est ça
qu'il faut qu'on essaie de défendre et
ce que je continuera à défendre puisque
vous parlez du dérèglement climatique de
violences orages ont touché les
Pyrénées-Orientales ces dernières heures
des vignes ont été touchées notamment
par la grêle est-ce que vous allez
prendre des mesures pour aider les
viticulteurs d'abord on va essayer de
quantifier les choses et de regarder les
choses une partie des vendanges étaient
faite dans les Pyrénées-Orientales c'est
quand même quelque chose de terrible
pour les Pyrénées-Orientales et c'est
quand même un message de soutien que je
j'envoie aux agriculteurs au territoire
concerné parce que sécheresse pendant un
an et quand quelque chose tombe c'est de
la graine donc il y a une forme de
désespérance on a fait un premier train
de mesure j'en parlais hier avec un des
responsables d'ailleurs des
Pyrénées-Orientales que je que je
croisais on est en train de regarder
c'était avant l'épisode de Noël des
mesures complémentaires sur la question
de la sécheresse après on a changé on a
réformé le modèle de l'assurance récolte
qui permet de mieux prendre en charge
c'est on a
on a plutôt bien marché cette année
d'ailleurs les agriculteurs ont plutôt
bien souscrits des contrats d'assurance
l'assurance doit prendre en charge des
gros accidents climatiques et l'État
elle est très gros c'est ça le principe
qu'on l'a posé donc on regardera dans le
détail et je voudrais juste dire qu'il
faut qu'on soit vraiment au côté de ces
agriculteurs et en particulier de ses
viticulteurs en l'occurrence qui qui
subissent et qui peuvent avoir le
sentiment que la succession d'Alea va
rendre impossible la capacité simplement
à produire dans ces territoires donc on
a à la fois à faire face à la crise et à
trouver des modèles qui leur permettent
de mieux résister à ses crises
ce titre ce ministre qu'est-ce que vous
diriez encore que la météo estivale a
été assez normale vous regardez les
récoltes il faut pas confondre le climat
et la météo c'est ce que vous allez me
dire mais c'est vous demander
aujourd'hui non puisque vous les
connaissez que j'ai croisé à Cambrai je
ne les ai pas entendu me dire qu'ils
avaient un été
radieux il m'a dit j'ai plutôt entendu
le mot pourri bon est-ce que ça change
le fait qu'il y a un dérèglement
climatique et qu'on ait des températures
moyennes qui soient plus élevées non
mais en instantané j'ai une production
de céréales cette année qui est en
augmentation de 6% sur le blé tendre et
qui sur la moyenne des cinq ans étant
augmentation de 3 à 4% c'est un fait ça
veut dire quoi ça veut dire qu'on a eu
moins de contraintes pourquoi parce
qu'on a eu
sécheresse
hivernal mais pas une sécheresse
paintonnière et estivale en tout cas
dans le Grand Nord de la France or les
départements qui plaît
Pyrénées-Orientales et une canicule qui
est arrivé tard au mois d'août dans mon
propre département on n'a pas dépassé
les 30 degrés jusqu'au 15 août donc
c'est une réalité et donc si on pouvait
avoir des débats c'est pas vous là pour
le coup ou quand on dit quelque chose
qui est juste un fait météorologique où
j'étais en Bretagne au Space j'ai
entendu les mêmes mots que ce que ceux
que j'ai entendu dans le Nord voilà
c'est pas faire griller il faut en
breton donc faut pas
se faire de querelles et ne pas dire
quand il fait 20 degrés il fait pas 40
degrés et non on n'est pas devenu
climato-sceptique et je ne suis pas
climato-sceptique j'ai monté une filière
bois énergie qui a 15 ans dans ma
collectivité j'ai fait de la
diversification végétale dans les
cantines il y a 15 ans donc mais si on
peut plus décrire une réalité sans faire
offense une espèce de c'est une espèce
de syntinquisition qui s'organise pour
pas décrire une réalité je pense qu'on
fait un grand tort à la cause que nous
défendons avec un certain nombre de ces
gens là c'est à dire la cause du
dérèglement climatique et de
l'adaptation on a une année qui est avec
des températures moyennes très élevées
mais avec des phénomènes extrêmes qui
ont plutôt touché le sud et pas le nord
cette année l'an dernier au mois de
juillet au moment où j'ai parlé de cette
question on avait déjà eu trois
canicules bref avec on les avait pas eu
au mois de juillet et les récoltes sont
sentis mais là on va parler du plan loup
Marc Créon que vous allez présenter dans
les prochains jours les attaques sur les
élevages se multiplient ce qu'il vaut
mieux réguler
faut qu'on trouve un équilibre sur cette
question d'abord faut quand même saluer
la réussite du plan louche j'ai dit ce
qui est plutôt audacieux au Space IRM ou
avant-hier
on avait un objectif de 500 loups et on
en a plus de 1100 bon donc on a plutôt
bien agi pour préserver cette espèce
dont vous ne trouverez pas sur le chemin
de la démagogie et que sur ça sur lequel
certains vont nous entraîner celui de
l'éradication jamais vous ne trouverez
sur chemin là et c'est bien qu'on est
des loups arrive un moment où victime de
notre succès d'une certaine façon et là
vous me trouverez sur ce chemin-là on
avait une vingtaine de départements il y
a 10 ans au début du plan nous on en
avait pas 500 il y a 5 ans là on en a
1100 il y a une croissance exponentielle
donc il faut qu'on ait des mécanismes
qui fassent qu'on arrive à tenir une
population démographiquement et
Génifique et génétiquement viable et qui
soit viable aussi dans les territoires
on a maintenant 55 départements de
toucher on a des élevages qui sont
touchés donc essayons de simplifier les
protocoles de tir j'écoute avec
attention ce qu'a dit Madame Van dere
pour vous on est déjà 19% on va déjà des
effectuer ce qu'il faut c'est qu'on
arrive à les faire on a réévalué tout de
suite avec les collègues du ministère de
la transition écologique donc c'est pas
ça peut pas être une querelle entre
l'écologie et l'agriculture pour moi il
faut qu'on on arrive à trouver un point
d'équilibre il y a plein de sujets je
reviendrai si vous voulez sur le loup
mais il y a plein de sujets sur lequel
il faut qu'on travaille ensemble pour
sauver l'autre forme d'autres formes de
biodiversité donc c'est compliqué de
trouver un équilibre sur cette question
qui est un peu passionnelle mais ne pas
trouver l'équilibre c'est à la fin
mettre en risque le loup parce qu'on
fait pas contre les populations locales
faut pas raconter l'histoire et de
mettre en risque une autre forme de la
biody de biodiversité parce que
l'élevage d'ovins en particulier mais
pas que demain il permet d'ouvrir les
paysages de lutter contre
comment donc de mettre en risque les
éleveurs et oui et donc et de mettre en
risque les éleveurs et le système et
l'écosystème qui protègent on sait tous
promener en montagne des paysages qu'on
a sous les yeux c'est des paysages qui
sont là parce qu'il y a des éleveurs et
le cortège de flore et de faune qu'on a
dans les prairies s'il y a plus
d'élevage ils sont broussaillera et il
brûlera est-ce qu'on a intérêt à ça donc
il faut qu'on trouve un point
d'équilibre on va essayer de trouver un
point d'équilibre de manière à apaisée
sur un certain objet et j'ai noté avec
intérêt on est dans un cadre européen
avec des règles européennes
que la présidente vanderleyen elle-même
a dit qu'il fallait réinterroger la
question mais il y a d'autres espèces
qui sont en risque et je ferai moins
sans doute des propositions avec le
monde agricole et auprès du monde
agricole pour regarder quels sont les
autres espèces animales ou végétales
qu'on doit essayer de préserver et qui
aujourd'hui sont plus en risque que le
loup essayons de traiter la biodiversité
je réserverai ces questions là avec mes
avec mes collègues de des ministères
concernés mais on a d'autres espèces qui
sont menacées il y a des rapaces qui
sont parfois menacés je sais le combat
contre certains sur les pollinisateurs
vous voyez donc la biodiversité c'est
pas que le loup et donc on a besoin de
travailler et là je vous le trouverez au
rendez-vous pour le faire avec les
agriculteurs et aux côtés de mes autres
collègues Julien vous avez une dernière
question pour marcenot alors pas Marcelo
le ministre maintenant on inquiète on
vous découvre monsieur chez nous vous
faites une apparition maritime dans un
épisode de la série de France Télé des
terres donc en tant que parents d'élèves
alors on a envie de vous poser la
question de savoir si c'est une nouvelle
carrière qui s'annonce je vois qu'en
fait c'est amusant parce que c'est un
clin d'œil qu'on a fait dans une série
qui est on est sur le dans un lycée
agricole la fiction est dans un lycée
agricole et gentiment ils m'ont proposé
de passer pour pour faire un clin d'œil
aux équipes aux acteurs ouvrez aux gens
dont c'est le métier c'est pas le cas je
ne suis pas en face de reconversion j'en
ai eu une intention politique est un
acteur comment le politique est un peu
faut pas faire d'être au théâtre non
plus oui ce que je veux dire chacun son
registre c'est pas une nouvelle carrière
qui s'ouvre non non c'était faire un
clin d'oeil aux équipes puis faire un
clin d'oeil aussi à l'enseignement
agricole donc c'est un peu oui
d'abord s'il me retienne et s'ils vont
trouver bon faut être modeste dans la
vie et deux c'était plutôt un clin
d'oeil aux équipes et à toutes les
équipes qui tournent et qui vont mettre
en valeur l'enseignement agricole et au
fond faire un regard sur l'agriculture
qui sont un peu différent c'est la
première fois qu'une fiction qui est
tournée sur l'agriculture
dans le registre de l'enseignement et
puis incliné aux équipes de
l'enseignement agricole donc je me suis
prêté au jeu
le rôle de ministre je me suis dit ça je
serais plus à l'aise parents d'élèves je
le suis par ailleurs
mais ce n'était pas mon fils merci Marc
Cheneau merci à vous